good to go
hello star talkies
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist i'm here at the tudor
city overpass
over 42nd street
in manhattan
on manhattanhenge day
this is may 30th you're seeing this live
if you're tuned in right at this moment
and this view is all the way across the
width of manhattan that's miles across
manhattan then across the hudson river
to the horizon that is new jersey
and unfortunately we get like weather
from new jersey so any clouds that are
going to come through jersey messes with
us but it looks like this is going to
work with us right now
i don't see any clouds a little bit of
haze a little bit of schmutz on the
horizon but
right now
there's
several hundred people here
on this overpass if you take a quick
look
let me like pivot that around
[Music]
and so
so this happens
twice a year
right manhattan has a perfect
rectangular grid
and we are on a cross street right now
that happens to cut completely through
not all cross streets will cut
completely through
further north
central park gets in the way further
south there's the streets that are not
straight left over from when we were
colonized by
the dutch when we were new amsterdam
they dug
you know they dug canals and things and
they didn't care about a grid the grid
came late in the 19th century and so
that's what we are taking advantage of
now
so twice a year this happens the sun
doesn't set straight to the horizon it
sets at an angle
for everyone
that lives any place other than the
equator if you
if you live on the equator
it'll always rise and set due east and
west
okay and it can angle like this but
always
when you're north of the tropic of
cancer north of 23 degrees
latitude on earth the sun will set at an
angle
okay which means right now the sun is
hiding
behind the buildings on the left side of
the street the south side of the street
very shortly
we will begin to see
reflection of the sunlight on the
buildings on the right-hand side of the
street on the northern side and this is
manhattan so buildings are made of like
steel and glass
so it makes for a very striking
phenomenon as that happened
and so i'm again i'm a little worried
i'm looking very low on the horizon
there and i'm seeing some like jersey
clouds very very low so i don't know how
deep we're going to get this manhattan
hinge phenomenon but everyone here is in
full anticipation of this
oh yeah say hi to my people right here
[Applause]
okay all right
[Music]
these people been here for hours by the
way
hours
okay
so
the origin of this
is i wanted i visited stonehenge when i
was a kid
when i was like 14 and i said this is
cool and there's these vertical stones
and the sun sets among them and i said
i'm a native new yorker and i got tall
buildings maybe we can do like a
manhattan hinge kind of thing so i went
to central park and i looked to see if
there are any alignments with the tops
of buildings behind the trees i spent a
lot of time trying i couldn't do it find
anything i said i'll just do the basic
one i know we got a grid
it looks somewhere on the eastern
horizon western horizon i calculated it
up took a photo of it in the year 2001
published it and then people started
paying attention then they started
flooding into the streets first hundreds
then thousands and now tens of thousands
of people are blocking traffic finally
for an excuse other than con ed digging
holes or police activity so
so
finally we can have a cosmic phenomenon
uh garnering the attention of the masses
as it should
so
we are
right now
10 minutes away
from
the sun setting exactly on the horizon
right here so tomorrow the sun is going
to set a little farther north and then
even farther north and they'll just keep
doing that until june 21st when it slows
down stops
solstice
stop the sun
okay
solstice is latin for stationary sun it
stops and then reverses then it comes
back through
this zone
so manhattan henge occurs on two
occasions
around memorial day
and then in the second week of july
now if you talk to anthropologists about
what ancient peoples did with the sun
there's always some connection with the
sun so i'm wondering
if in like apocalyptic earth
where they'll dig up the grid of
manhattan it'll say hey that aligns with
the sun
on this day of the year and that day
what did they do on those days of the
year well one is a memorial day and the
other one is around baseball's all-star
break so they would conclude that
whatever country this was it was all
about war and baseball i'm thinking
because that's what the sun aligns on
our grid
so
you see it's getting bright right now
in the upper sections i'm still worried
about the clouds i think there are
clouds there very low down
there's some clouds very low down so the
sun is gonna have to punch through the
clouds to give us something good
so
we're checking it out right now i don't
know if you can see from that angle
the people all through 47 we're between
first and second avenue you just get a
sense of the distancing here next is 2nd
avenue 3rd avenue 4th avenue which is
park avenue then 5th avenue 6th avenue
7th 8th 9th 10th 11th 12th west street
hudson river that's another mile
and then the palestinians in new jersey
don't worry
again worried about those clouds coming
in
got everybody in here look at that
so
i'm loving it
i'm loving it yes uh a few years ago a
manhattan henge
was absorbed up into the oxford english
dictionary so very honored by that that
they viewed it as they have
all kinds of words are lifted up every
year so
you know okay
they caught up with manhattan hedge and
so that's in the oxford english
dictionary now and i'm just delighted
that the city can participate in a
cosmic event
where people stopped arguing about
whatever they were arguing and
everybody's here together
and the universe has a way
of doing just that for us all i think
all agree do you think the universe
doesn't yeah the universe can uh
can exalt
cosmic thoughts
can take your thoughts high above
the basal
points of argument that always goes on
among us
so
there it is right in the middle of the
shot you might be able to see
also
[Applause]
[Music]
the drone has the best view of the whole
thing
yeah
uh yeah i know
i know next time we're going to do this
on a drone for sure
oh yeah we got two drones over there we
got drone battle
right there
oh yeah you must have went to skydesk
so new yorkers will get together you
know
i know occasionally like we shoot people
on the subways and stuff but
that's just occasion that's just
occasionally
cars are getting into it
now if you can also see the chrysler
building i don't know if that's in view
uh there's lighting for it it was
striking at night
okay and so now
yeah
i don't know that they normally turn
them on soon
yeah it could be you get across the
front of it you know like yeah that
could happen
so
this is yes
we are
live
that how you know it's live i'll show
you my watch watch okay
got like 806. okay what time what does
digital time happen i have to wind up my
watch people
are two
my watch is fast sorry
because i had to i i had to like set it
this morning and then wind it like right
there let me reset it
oh yeah
so uh when i first
came up
with this idea i thought to myself
surely you could do this in any city
in all cities of the world just find a
street that terminates on the western
horizon and then i realized no
many cities are in valleys which means
your horizon goes to build it to to
mountains
uh other cities the streets aren't
straight
so they don't form a grid
this is three miles of 42nd street but
notice right now the north side of the
street is getting illuminated by
it's reflecting to us that's a very good
sign
and so
so i thought there'd be other city i
thought this would be coming but it
turned out it's like no no sorry about
that
there's like there's no i'm not having
that so there's like a house on the
right and a tree on the left and it's
setting on the street
but the hinging of it is total vertical
structures
buildings that go high like in
stonehenge itself
so
so how come people didn't do this like
50 years ago 100 years ago the grid
comes from the 19th century
and it's because i think
i think
you're not going to be crossing the
street
and
looking to the horizon when a car could
hit you
so you are looking carefully as you
cross the street where you're stepping
is the car going to hit you i want to
get to the sidewalk as quickly as
possible plus
right now it's after work hours so you
don't have to busy
coming home
but
also if the sun is in your eyes the
sun's in my eyes let me keep going
there's all these reasons why you would
not engage this phenomenon especially in
new york where nobody has a relationship
with the sky
so we're coming in good
i love it
it's coming into view that you see some
police uh
activity there they should let they
should just close the street where are
you going now wait wait wait what are
you doing where you going just just
please get out of the street let people
be the street
i don't think they heard that i don't
think
what you're saying let me go tell them
yeah you go to town
i got people here
i got people here go tell them okay
all right
so
um other cities it turns out it's rarer
than i thought it would ever be you go
to la they have the sunset strip okay so
the sun sets on that street in some
segments on some days of the year but
it's not a straight street it curves
right so
how many streets have perfect grits even
washington dc has grid
however it's a circular coordinate
system right it's not a rectangular
coordinate system so
i had not appreciated
how rare
this phenomenon actually is so and you
are now wherever you are in the world
you are participating live and you do
have the right time now it's 805.
[Music]
what time digital people what time you
have
806 thank you okay
okay
so the sun should appear in a matter of
moments
okay
the rotation of the earth will move the
sun
its own diameter every two and a half
minutes or so
we're not trying to hide you guys okay
and so
oh my gosh so excited
the sun tripod legs here
[Music]
there's nothing but tripods here it's
all tripod move forward a little bit
[Music]
this is
okay
so where was i
sorry guys oh by the way just so you
know about
42nd street uh
can we turn it yeah yeah so that's the
united nations
back there you show everybody
that's the united nations right there
see that okay
united nations
wow okay okay
there we go
okay
how are we doing here
okay sure here comes the sun
what's that beetle song
[Laughter]
so wherever you are in the world again
this happens twice a year
on two consecutive days on the first of
the two hens days half of the sun is
below the horizon
when it sets on the grid the day after
that in may the full sun is on the
horizon
but right now you now you can see the
clouds
that are there i'm hoping to have some
transparency
so that
we can get
the beautiful orb of the sun but i think
that's not what we're going to get today
yeah i love it traffic is completely
stopped
i love stopping traffic in manhattan
for this
the universe
so we need like some
music like
like the music from 2001 you know
[Music]
oh he's got here comes the sun yeah he's
got the guy
got it you know he got it you know he's
got it
all
now it's a thousand people in the tree
by the way this is for every cross
street that cuts through manhattan so
34th street 14th street 23rd street uh
even the tiny those are all the two-way
cross streets yeah thank you there's all
two across streets even on the one-way
courses that are narrow you would still
get this there's probably fewer people
on those streets and here's what's cool
the sun is basically at infinity okay
and
it's light upon reaching manhattan is
all parallel
so it'll hit every single cross street
simultaneously
so everyone in every cross street
manhattan is lit on both its north and
south sides when so often
one side of the street is shadowed
because we have the canyons of manhattan
so
i've always embraced
what manhattan henge does as the north
and south sides of the street
turn aglow
so
so i said the sun will continue to set
as the days go by
more and more north the sun will spend
more time in the sky between sunrise and
sunset we call that summertime right and
then beginning june 21st the sun will
set on its way back and we'll have a
reprise of this
on june
on july 11th
everyone will be here again
to check out this same phenomenon
and by the way in order for it to work
and to people who see it and appreciate
it's got to be clear right it's clear
above our heads but jersey's got the
clouds okay
just blank jersey any people native to
new jersey here oh yeah oh oh right guys
right here
sorry sorry about that yeah okay
okay we got more jersey people right
here y'all get back to your state okay
why why you gotta do this
[Laughter]
actually jersey gets its weather from
pennsylvania there's a prevailing west
to east weather patterns across the
united states so if you want to know
what whether you're going to have
tomorrow just look
you look west
and so right now
there it is
yeah
[Music]
it's a traffic i love it
you can just make out the disc of the
sun
give that an applause all right
[Applause]
[Music]
you know it's funny a few years ago i
was here
and i had on my hat and glasses and
i um
i was in front just trying to get some
pictures and there was a
there's a old lady in the back
that said
down in front sonny
and so i wanted to say
if it wasn't for me you wouldn't even be
here
i said no okay i'll get them
because she was trying to appreciate the
event and i didn't want to be in her way
so
but
but i i thought it for a moment but i
thought that no that'd be that'd be me
you want to spread the cosmic love of
all that it is
so
i think we're good here
this this has been
star talk live
live
uh and
are we on two channels here uh instagram
and youtube
hey hey guys
live
by the way i see many drones i mean
we're gonna drone this next time
i'll find a human drone where i can then
be in the drone myself that'd be cool
while doing a podcast that's totally
will do that okay i never touched a
human being before in my life
this is an awesome it is it's totally
it's what it is to be human
okay
okay everybody so i'm going to say
goodbye
and you all say goodbye right here okay
say goodbye to instagram youtube
okay
all right excellent bye everybody all
right
you can probably get it i love john
cosmos man yeah oh thank you yeah
trying to keep the universe going
you can get through that way
you can get you can get through that
right